you brought a Beckham you said you
really like the documentary oh yeah I've
been hearing about this documentary is
good it's the first Travis uh Kelsey and
Taylor Swift the OG yeah that's a good
ass point that is a good ass Point did
you see it I my wife's been watching it
so I've been like picking up little
parts and uh and like she'll pass out
and I'll just keep watching that's how I
know if something's good yeah and uh
like really fun he's great he's great
and obviously it's a documentary so it's
accentuating like the best parts of him
I thought it was I don't know soccer so
you tell me it felt like o like like
Jordan documentary he's
undeniably top two at the very least
best basketball player of all time in
the entire history of the Universe I
don't ever hear people put Beckham top
five top 10 and the way they're talking
about him it's like this is the greatest
player to ever set foot on grass to me I
thought he was cuz that was the only
player I heard of as a young kid in
soccer so he he was the icon but as like
my friends who knew soccer were like
yeah he's good yeah it
I my takeaway maybe because I already
knew that he was he was a really good
player but not like the number one guy
in the world at the time my take with it
was more like personality wise like I I
saw him as like a quite well-rounded
individual like not too pompous or
arrogant like like kind of hardworking
player and until was the guy Sir
Alex fuson like until they you know he
separated went and played in Real Madrid
or whatever like kind of like humble
most respectful of this guy who was his
coach since he was a teenager which I
didn't expect from him you know like I
don't I didn't yeah he comes off almost
like a kind of workingclass bloke yeah
which I knew him as like a fashion icon
yeah see like really refreshing to see
like I felt the he was closer to that
than he was portraying himself and it
was just like I feel I mean like the guy
was modeling and then he acts like dude
I just wanted to be play football and
like I don't know what's happening
around me I miss the birth of my
daughter to go do a photo shoot with JLo
and Beyonce but like I just I'm just a
workingclass bloke who loves Guinness
and the genius of documentary like can
curate however you want but I saw this
one clip going around she was capping
she was like oh yeah I grew up middle
class dude this is the genius though is
he does that to his wife and then nobody
does that to him but you watch that
moment and you're like yo they did they
were authentic in the documentary she be
capping more than him though yeah yeah
he he don't really brag a lot you know
what I mean he like reacts to the game
and they do a really cool visual effect
where he's watching the game through the
L so they can you get like his so
visually imagine there's a camera behind
the screen that he's watching the game
so you get his like in the- moment
reactions to his plays he's watching
like this he's looking your eyes yeah
it's really cool but uh he did cap on
the affair thing though like they kind
of touch on it a little bit and he was
like that was like a really tough time
for us man people were trying to tear us
apart and it's like tough time for us
you you throw us thought Victoria and I
had to fight for each other she was
yelling at you for two years straight
like what this is a very funny but did
he [__] the girl like what was the deal
yeah I'm fairly certain he it was enough
that he had to address it and if he
didn't [__] her he'd probably take that
documentary to be like I didn't touch
this girl what are you guys talking
about oh yeah exactly yeah he didn't
never say he didn't do it yeah he was
just like we had to really fight to save
our marriage it was important for us to
be there for each other and it's like
well this is a funny way of putting it
yeah that's why I felt like he capped
when he needed to cap she capped on like
I'm working class and he capped on like
I'm faithful yeah I'm a great husband a
work classy sounds good how good was he
yeah that's what I want I mean he was
like the star of England arguably okay
like he was like their guy set peace
dude like winning like you see it in the
documentary like when he gets the red
card and they lose on PKS to Brazil or
whatever or Argentina uh like they blame
him because he was like a Lynch pin he
was the captain of England so when
you're the captain of a country that is
like the epicenter of like European
soccer you're raised to a higher level
of course you like being the best player
on the Knicks you don't have to be the
best player or the best player on the
Cowboys the quarterback you don't have
to be the best for your health and then
he's also married and has a kid with the
biggest pop star in eng and then he's
also extremely handsome like he's so hot
dude it's crazy yeah yeah you didn't
realize it when he's younger shaves his
head gets hotter that's when I was like
this guy's a smoke sh who's Who's hotter
him or Ronaldo oh David Beckham is on
another planet I think it's Beckham dude
I think it's be another planet beckh
when you see him with the shaved head
you're like dude this guy is sex pure
sex pure sex dude but to be a star
joying this yeah watch it dude and
you'll see what I mean what other
athlete is as handsome as Beckham
LeBron why y'all laugh bro I mean I said
it so y'all would laugh but that's how
you feel about LeBron y' just laugh no
he's not no he's not David Beckham yeah
yeah I know I I think LeBron that I
think if he saw like I a no Beck yeah
LeBron's toes alone I think disqualify
from the Beckham combo Tiger Woods n n
come on that's what I'm saying bro
there's not even close no one that's as
good that's as handsome it's very rare
it's I mean Tom Brady is the only other
one oh Tom Brady Tom Brady and Ronaldo
and and Ronaldo's gorgeous man okay so
documentary you thought was fair to his
skill level like he
was he was excelling and doing some
pretty cool things for the teams he was
playing for yeah absolutely I thought so
but I'm also like tainted I grew up like
watching him and being like Oh yeah this
is the best I bought the cleats I was
like dude [__] yeah the the dust in
it could he do something that other
players couldn't do that bendit [__] cuz
that's the only thing I heard from him
the only reason I found out about him
was from the movie I was little salty
and bring up that movie by the way he
was good at set pieces and had like
legendary free kicks at like one insane
games so he had some very clutch moments
and then he also was very good at
setting people up around the net right
so it's it's weird like when you're a
casual soccer fan it doesn't seem like
it's hard to just kick the ball high and
then people head it in but placing that
I guess is a very difficult skill and
you have to be really good at it so
people respected his assisting ability
is that fair I I think so again I'm not
like an expert in Beckham I didn't like
watch him at the time with like soccer
IQ yeah but yeah I mean he was like
known for set pieces yeah and so Corners
free kicks and like having clutch
moments it was 2002 World Cup where he
they won against Greece this might be OD
but was there a time when was considered
the the best player in the world in the
world not of all time in the world cuz
at the time he's playing against OG
Ronaldo Ronaldo who was like Unstoppable
he wasn't the best player on his team
that's yeah when he was playing Real
Madrid like there was probably multiple
people that were better yeah and yeah
that's where I was like I feel like
they're the way they talk it's the same
way they talk about Jordan on the last
dance and that's a Fluff piece but it's
in Jordan so but he might be the most
famous in the world yeah and it was cool
the owner of the real there's a really
cool moment where they the owner they
asked the owner of Real Madrid like why
did you sign him you already had this
other guy named Luis Figo I think it was
his name because you already had this
other guy named Luis Figo playing on the
right and um the owner just goes uh
because he was going to make us millions
of
dollars triple Revenue Tri Tri revenue
and literally they're doing these what
do they called friendlies or something
like that they take the team on the road
and they play these games like they'll
do it sometimes at MetLife for Yankee
Stadium here and it's just an
opportunity for people to go see these
iconic teams in different places but
they get paid so much [__] money to
do something like that oh really so you
add a superstar Like Beckham who's the
most popular player in the world at this
time you take him to [__] China and
the circus around him is crazy I mean I
yeah the fame level is nuts that's
something that I admire how they handled
it like yeah okay you got some [__] on
his side or whatever but like that's
also true their ability to withstand
that type of pressure yeah that's true
and remain somewhat normal yeah like
both of them seem kind of cool when you
talk to them like and I don't mean cool
in terms
of um what how they look or dress like I
don't give a [__] about the tattoos and
[__] grounded yeah like like grounded
like she seems kind of dope she's kind
of like funny like she don't even really
lik soccer she's like and she says she's
like I just liked him at one point she's
like I'm going to work and they're like
no where you really going she's like get
a
facial like she's like referential and
like where she's at I don't know I
thought it was cool I like them yeah
they're they're quite interesting that's
a good point you're to be that famous
and not you see what it does to people
man even if you're acting a little more
humble than you are to not be a complete
eag Maniac nutbag at that level of Fame
you got to commend that yep to go and
open the door to the room and say to
your wife yeah when you're making your
documentary what type of car was it well
there's a situation what type of car one
answer yeah Rolls-Royce yeah fantastic
and for her to do it and let it be out
there cool fantastic and that's funny I
guess I have to watch this because I
thought they were the opposite I didn't
think they were think cuz I thought they
started the trend like naming their kids
like some stupid ass name they they did
a little bit I feel like they yeah then
it's was like then Apple and all these
stupid ass names came out you know
what's so funny about that is that when
I saw how young they
were it was like he like 23 he's like 23
or 24 like you're a kid with a kid so
what would a kid do you know what I mean
like I remember judging it but now that
I'm [__] 39 years old and I'm seeing
like a 23 or 24y old kid who's like into
looking cool fashion hairstyles what you
the same thing is going to be projected
on your son you're not going to be like
let me find a Regal name that he'll be
okay with when he's a be like no I'm
going to name him Ferrari not even that
bad say again Harper Cruz Romeo and
Brooklyn the first two are Brooklyn and
Romeo I think after that they're like
all right let's chill the [__] out bit
yeah I heard Cruz I heard I don't know
if this is true is named after Tom Cruz
get out of here that's a little
apparently Beckham was so Star Struck
when he met Tom Cruz he was like dude
this is unbel that's a little weird
apparently that's what they said cheat
on her with a
dude that's the Scientology money that's
that's what happened [__] they they were
both going through a hard time